all right well border patrol reporting
mass groups of migrants arriving in the
del rio sector with agents encountering
more than 2 500 migrants this weekend
alone and there are concerns things will
get even worse as we learn the pandemic
era policy title 42 may end as early as
tomorrow to explain we have bill malugen
he is an eagle pass texas hi bill
hey dana good morning to you that's
exactly right the del rio sector where
we are right now has been absolutely
hammered in recent weeks their numbers
are up more than 200 percent year over
year the border patrol stations here way
over capacity so the federal government
is now mass releasing migrants into
local communities to take the pressure
off take a look at this video shot right
here in eagle pass yesterday drone video
showing dozens of illegal immigrants
crossing the rio grande and entering
into the state of texas illegally some
of them just waiting across the river
others using boats this is something
that happens day in day out multiple
times a day here in the eagle pass area
as these bigger groups are being
encountered more and more often to that
point take a look at this photo right
here this was one massive single group
of
187 illegal immigrants encountered on
sunday by border patrol here in eagle
pass it was mostly made up of
nicaraguans and cubans but border patrol
says they've been seeing these huge
single groups almost every single day
and that is causing huge overcrowding in
their border facilities and this is the
result of what happens with that if we
can pull up this video right here mass
releases into local communities what
you're looking at is video posted by uh
representative tony gonzalez's office
yesterday showing a group of about 300
illegal immigrants being mass released
at an ngo right here in eagle pass texas
this ngo has been taking in several
hundred migrants who have been released
every single day and the federal
government has been doing these mass
releases in little towns and cities all
across del rio sector del rio here in
eagle pass carrizo springs uvalde we
caught up with the mayor of uvalde
yesterday and he is not happy about
what's going on take a listen
we're not equipped to handle these
people
i get paid 50 bucks a month to be mayor
the last thing i want you to be handling
is an immigration issue that the federal
government should be having instead of
dumping it on communities like ours
and guys suddenly dhs has announced that
they are going to start requiring
migrants who go into federal custody to
get the covid19 vaccine and that begs
the question why now all of a sudden
this has been going on for over a year
the federal government has been mass
releasing these migrants into the united
states hundreds of thousands of them for
over a year now without vaccines why the
sudden change could it possibly be
because we are hearing on our end that
title 42 could be dropping imminently
potentially within just a matter of days
we'll find out that's a good question
for the white house today indeed thank
you so much bill